These are steps that the United States will take to improve prosperity,...
...security and human dignity in the Asia Pacific.
We will do so through our close friendship with Japan,...
...which will always be a centerpiece of our efforts in the region.
We will do so as a partner, through the broader engagement that I've discussed today.
We will do so as a Pacific nation,...
...with a president who was shaped in part by this piece of the globe.
And we will do so with the same sense of purpose...
...that has guided our ties with the Japanese people for nearly 50 years.
The story of how these ties were forged dates back to the middle of the last century,...
...sometime after the guns of war had quieted in the Pacific.
It was then that America's commitment to the security and stability of Japan,...
...along with the Japanese people's spirit of resilience and industriousness,...
...led to what's been called, the Japanese miracle.
A period of economic growth that was faster and more robust than anything the world had seen for some time.
In the coming years and decades, this miracle would spread throughout the region...
...and in a single generation,...
...the lives and fortunes of millions were forever changed for the better.
It is progress that has been supported by a hard-earned peace...
...and strengthened by new bridges of mutual understanding...
...that have bound together the nations of this vast and sprawling space.